bring in florida congressman byron
donalds for some thoughts on this so
let's put up the scene at lincoln
hospital in the bronx over the weekend
you had hundreds of illegal migrants who
were lined up outside they were getting
free health care they were getting free
food they were even getting free phones
and some people take a look at this and
they're outraged because they say look
there are plenty of people in new york
city who cannot make ends meet why are
we taking care of illegal uh migrants
but here's the thing i mean they were
dropped there in new york city uh with
probably not much to their names but
then at the same time
you've got these towns on the border
that are just
crumbling under the under the crush of
all of these illegal migrants so
a lot of people in the country look at
this and say well you've got to take
care of them but then why can't you take
care of other people and i'm wondering
what are you thinking about all of this
what i think is is that if you have
democrat politicians not just joe biden
but people like mark kelly of arizona
cortez masto of nevada mayor adams of
new york mayor bowser of washington d.c
if they support this kind of a policy at
our border then they should be
responsible for the consequences you
have border towns all throughout the
southern border who never asked for a
wide open border joe biden wanted to do
it democrat politicians have supported
it so they need to be the ones to pay
for it it's just that simple if you have
border towns bear the burden while
liberals in the northeast get to ignore
the problem that they created you're
only going to get more of a problem what
is happening is a political political
and humanitarian catastrophe but this is
brought to us by the democrat party so
these major blue cities they should be
the ones that have to deal with some of
the burden being caused by their
terrible border policy so the governors
of texas and arizona greg abbott and
doug ducey are coming in for criticism
from from democrats for putting people
on buses and it's voluntary people have
to volunteer to go and then sending them
to either washington d.c or new york
city but at the very same time that
these two governors are coming under
criticism the federal government
congressman is sending thousands of
people on airplanes buses and other
forms of transportation across the
country
to settle them in cities that are
already overburdened when it comes to
social services
you're absolutely right the federal
government has been doing that since
last february if you've flown american
airlines or southwest airlines anywhere
through the united states there have
been illegal immigrants who are on those
planes there is the refugee resettlement
office has been setting up all of this
but it's bigger than that joe biden's
border policy is subsidizing the drug
cartels the drug cartels are going to
make 15 billion dollars a year and i
don't hear democrats complaining about
migrants who are being trafficked into
the united states by the drug cartels i
don't hear them complaining about the
drug cartels making billions of dollars
more per year and i don't hear their i
don't hear them complaining about the
young girls who are being raped and yes
i said raped in the journey of being
trafficked by the drug cartels when it
comes to that they got nothing to say
because they want the open border policy
but when abbott and ducey send them to
new york and dc now they're complaining
it is hypocrisy at its worst and the
washington post editorial board
basically sent a signal to mayor muriel
bowser of washington d.c uh you better
get ready because this isn't going to
end the editorial saying d.c can't wish
away migrant buses the city must prepare
for more but congressman there's another
problem here some 250 000 unaccompanied
minors have been resettled in this
country
which when they become adults is going
to put us in another crisis position
where you have to decide what to do with
them do you initiate deportation
proceedings against them or does this
become daca 2.0
look in my view you have to begin the
process of deportation proceedings joe
biden's allowed for all of this and it's
not just him like i said you have
democrats in the senate who've not
lifted a finger to actually stop this
problem they encourage it so what are
you going to do you're going to inundate
the united states with millions of
people through this reckless policy and
then say oh oops now we have to make
them citizens or put them on a pathway
to citizenship that is a terrible policy
nobody supports it the democrats can't
pass it in congress so they're going to
do it with the blunt force of no
enforcement at the southern border so
everybody's got to deal with that
question terrible politics but this is
what happens when you have a party
committed to ideology as opposed to the
facts on the ground and what it means in
so many cities across the country
congressman bob mcdonald's always good
to catch up with you from the great
state of florida thanks for joining us
appreciate it
anytime hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now